yeah i don't know it's it's just it's
fascinating to watch
especially i i'd say in like the last
two or three years
of just all these people just suddenly
coming out you know saying how do you
feel about
how do you feel about anime being like
way more how do i feel about
i was trying to think of the right word
because is it mainstream yet
that's the eternal debate isn't it yeah
it's like is it truly mainstream yet
i think so i i it depends on your
definition of mainstream right
i mean it's not like everyone's talking
about 24 7 but no is everyone
you know i mean people argued that like
you know oh demon slayer was trending on
twitter
right it must have gone mainstream and
i'm like i don't think it's mainstream
yeah i think it's
like about three four years away from
like properly being mainstream i'd say
i don't know i feel like every time
there's a big show it helps a lot yeah
it's certainly on its way i mean attack
on titan season four will hopefully help
a lot
in terms of like hey here is a completed
masterpiece
hopefully i mean the the amount of money
that the [ __ ] demon slayer movie made
in like the first like two weeks of it
coming out i mean it's still like dwarf
numbers compared to like
proper uh proper giant blockbusters
45 which is amazing but yeah i mean
like [ __ ] avengers got like a billion in
like the first weekend that's
ridiculous which is obviously like you
know comparison but then again if i
heard robert downey jr's voice in demon
slayer it would probably get me yeah i
mean
and again it is japan so it's kind of a
very isolated market yeah so it's kind
of hard to say
like how well it would do yeah that's
that's why i'd say that it's
still like a few years from being like
properly mainstream but at this point
it's not like anime itself isn't
mainstream but at least
pretty much everyone knows what anime is
now it's it's it's
it's accepted yeah there's never this
debate of
you mention an anime and people are like
what what the f
what language what is an anime
i think that you know there's 40 50 year
olds online who you talk to who get all
the anime references and keep up with it
but i've got
25 year old friends in the uk who are
like what's that
like what's that no what's that legit
like so it's
it's it's i think we almost get our like
perceptions skewed
especially ours because we are
surrounded by like
like-minded individuals to an extent
yeah we're surrounded people online
yeah we never interact with people
really outside of the online bubble
even when we leave our house right we're
normally going to an event with other
online people or people who work in the
same industry right but yeah
when i go back to the uk or i go back to
wales and i talk to my friends
they literally have like no [ __ ] clue
about any anime
maybe they'll be like what's that uh um
that one punch man or something you know
but the fact that they've heard about
that yeah they might but they're my age
i would expect them to be like come on
yeah for 24. you should know what death
note is come on yeah i mean like
with titles like that as long as you're
on the internet it's pretty [ __ ] hard
to avoid right yeah yeah i i mean like
it's weird because like when when you go
into those kind of social circles and
you realize oh
you don't spend all your time on twitter
and uh seeing seeing all the
[ __ ] drama and everything happening
on online you're just
you're just watching [ __ ] love island
or whatever and just like happy with
that
[ __ ] hate reality tv that's like
that's like a whole new world but even
some people that i know who you know
don't spend any time on the internet and
everything like that still i've heard of
some some of these like bigger shows
and to me that is still like a massive
step
than what it was even like five years
ago and like going back to tennis you
had to like
seek out that [ __ ] yeah the only reason
i started youtube was to make friends so
i could speak to you about it
all right and now i don't really want to
speak about it
i mean i do i just [ __ ] these friends i
i mean again going back to the podcast
it's like
i i did want to speak about it but i
didn't want to make a whole podcast
talking about it i want to make a
podcast and talk [ __ ]
i mean the only reason why we labeled
ourselves in anime podcast is because
all three of us individually
i guess it was established in that field
i guess it was like a comfort thing but
then when we got on the flow of it i
think we realized that like i think us
just chatting is like
because i remember like when we first
were conceptualizing this podcast
we were like all right let's just like
maybe like the first like 10 or 20
episodes we should like solely focus on
the stuff that people
know us for and then maybe every now and
then you know
the whole time i'm like i'm like i do
not want to do this so we'll slide in
some other stuff and then
you know episode one rolls around don't
mention anime a single time
i think we only talked about attack on
titan for like 20 minutes yeah first
episode
i've watched a lot of anime podcasts you
know i mean i've watched
what do you think about them okay well
this is the thing right there's only so
much you can [ __ ] say about anime
yeah i feel like a lot of the times it's
like three or four people who
regurgitate the same point with slightly
different wording at
back to each other than like um yes i
agree yeah and it's like okay
cool i mean some people some people are
looking for that but to me it's like not
exciting anymore
i don't know why because there's so many
so much of it out there there's too much
anime and by the
and i've gotten to the point now where i
i don't really have as much time as i'd
like
to do everything that i want to do yeah
so now i just wait until the season's
over and i'm like
right so what was the best show guys
what was the uh what was the what was
that what was the show
because because i feel like out of the
three of us i probably watch the most
yeah you do you do yeah i'm the most
normally here everyone knows that yeah
and
we've got like a spectrum here where
joey's like i don't even watch anime
anymore i just read manga yeah even
though i'm like called the anime man
he's the anime man who reads more manga